PFT ot Thursday edition before we
unleash Chris on his family for the
weekend we have some questions leftover
from the call that we made both to the
PFT p.m. policy and to the Chris Sims
unbuttoned homies so let's answer a few
of them look you could say it's lazy
that we didn't actually sit down and
come up with a topic that we're letting
you do the work for us you could say all
those things and they would be accurate
that's exactly what we did every once in
a while we don't want to think of a
topic we let you think of the topic
Chris here's the first topic that is on
the minds of the PFT p.m. Posse and this
comes straight from the official PFT
p.m. posse account what do you see
happening with players and teams that
have multi-year big-money contracts if
the cap has a huge drop in 2021 due to
the absence of revenue from ticket sales
and also popcorn and beer and hot dogs
and everything else that goes along with
the gameday experience will star players
have to cut or be cut in order to get
under the cap or will the NFL on the
NFLPA come up with some other
alternative Chris this is a real issue
because we've always seen the cap go up
and up and up and up and as you sign
players to contracts you know there's
gonna be more money next year than there
is this year up but next year there
could be less than there is this year
and it could put some teams in a real
squeeze could we see in your view an
influx of a bunch of veteran players who
are overpriced who get dumped because
the cap has been slashed I do think so I
do I think it's a very real possibility
now I also think it's a possibility NFL
does find a way here just to figure out
some formula that maybe make sense to
save some of those type of casualties
where you know a team gets to you know
oh hey these three guys are cornerstones
of our franchise and only half their
contract counts against the salary cap
or something like that for the 2021
season I can see that happening but I
don't know I haven't heard rumors but
yeah I think four star players who are
underperforming and maybe the team looks
at him and goes ooh they're not worth
what we're paying certainly in big-time
trouble of being released or cut and
then I think the other thing is
renegotiating contracts you know and
trying to
figure out a way to where it makes sense
for that 2021 season to make that number
fit to wear me up maybe you have to give
a guy more of us you know a new signing
bonus when you redo his contract or
whatever but it lessens the number for
that yearly hit I think you're gonna see
a lot of that type of juggling going on
but what do you say cuz I know you got a
better feel for this stuff than I do and
this is another reminder of why I like
taking questions because sometimes the
questions force me to consider things in
a way that I otherwise just wouldn't
sitting around thinking about whatever
the news of the day is here's the
reality every year the salary cap is the
product of a negotiation between the NFL
and the NFL Players Association they
pick the number together and the teams
aren't going to want to see a dramatic
drop in the salary cap because they want
to avoid having to cut key players
having to restructure contracts they'd
rather not restructure and when we
consider that before too long there's
going to be a recovery financially
there's going to be new money that gets
pumped into the NFL's coffers via the
next wave of broadcast deals they could
essentially borrow against future salary
caps they could prop up next year's and
take it from future years so instead of
having an explosion in the cap when the
new TV deals kick in they could keep the
cap steady next year and make up the
shortfall in the future years when more
money pours in it's almost essentially
the the owners loaning themselves money
to pay players knowing that in future
years when there's more money coming in
less of it goes to the players but
that's an easy fix Chris and I hadn't
thought of that until just now the
salary cap could be the exact same next
year and the owners get their credit in
future years when the revenue not only
recovers but moves north with the new TV
deals if I had to guess I think that's
the outcome we're not going to see a dip
in the salary cap we're going to see it
the same maybe even a little bit higher
just to show everyone hey we're fine and
then the money from future years is
what's going to subsidize the the
ability to keep the cap at or close to
where it is in 2021 yeah it'll be
interesting
and really will I you know I I hear what
you're saying but that's also all
predicated on all the economies and they
get turned around and be somewhere in a
positive you know spot here six seven
eight months from now and I'm just not
sure that's the reality so again like I
think that thought and what you're
saying makes a whole lot of sense I'm
just not sure again it's gonna be one of
those things we're gonna have to wait
and see we're gonna have to see what the
the you know jobless rate is in America
the unemployment rate and then to see
what what kind of fan attendants do we
get this year you know as restrictions
get eased and things like that how
comfortable are people going to a
stadium and consuming you know these
products and being in a place where
other people are touching the hand
railings and everything else you know I
think those are all things that are
gonna play into what you're saying and I
don't think we're gonna have those
answers for a while and the clock the
clock Chris is ticking on these TV deals
the Monday Night Football deal expires
after the 2021 season the rest of the
contracts expire after the 2022 season I
could see the NFL doing kind of a
short-term band-aid deal just to wait
until everything is back to normal or as
close to normal as its ever gonna be
when the big money can be spent by the
network's to do a longer-term deal but
if there's concern that's gonna take
time for the economy to recover I think
it makes sense for the NFL to go
short-term but again that that is going
to delay the day when the NFL gets that
that huge increase in writes fees that
it was anticipating getting once it got
a new labor deal in place next question
from Brian Donohue 56 do you see
temperatures being taken of every fan at
the gates before going through a metal
detector of course this is all premise
Thanh fans showing up and Chris let me
just answer this one quickly I watched
60 minutes this week there was a segment
about what's going on at Amazon with all
the people that are working to ensure
that all the things we order show up
they actually have a scan that they do
of you that doesn't touch you like as
you come through the doors it catches
your temperature so I think at a minimum
they're gonna do that and anybody that's
got a fever isn't gonna be allowed in it
doesn't mean they're not carrying the
virus but right at least a basic litmus
test to say hey if you've got a fever
you're not coming through the doors yeah
I mean I guess
real possibility how expensive is that
technology to be the other question I
asked you know and just man how long
will that slow down the process of
people getting into the stadiums I mean
that's not a big deal we know but it'll
certainly be a pain in the butt so I
mean it makes sense that would be the
correct thing to do you know and again
we don't know if that's not gonna be
foolproof as you said there's a lot of
asymptomatic carriers of this virus out
there who have no clue never showed any
signs no fever anything like that so
you're still gonna be taking a
tremendous risk in that scenario but
this just this type of formula or
scenario would lessen that to a degree
you know I don't know but Amazon's got
more money than anybody in the world so
they can afford that type of technology
you know the NFL is you know unwilling
to put 30 to sky judges in a stadium or
have somebody there to look at the
proper inflation's of the football
because they don't want to spend money
are they gonna spend millions of dollars
on temperature machines outside of each
stadium I don't know I don't know how
much it's gonna cost I'm feeling the
technology isn't ridiculously expensive
and from the time angle there's gonna be
plenty of time to scan people's
temperatures because when they do let
fans back in I think it's going to be a
slow progression to your seat because
they're not gonna just open the gates
and let people flood in Mark Cuban the
Mavericks owner was talking about how
the the NBA is planning for that
eventualities where you basically are
ushered to your seats one at a time can
you imagine how long it's gonna take to
get in and to get out of a stadium
people may stay away just because it's a
pain in the butt to get your seat and to
get to your car
given the efforts to keep people
properly separated all right Aussie
Chiefs fan loved the show Mike I would
love to get Chris Sims opinion on how
Trevor Lawrence compares to Patrick
mahomes in terms of arm strength arm
angles on throws accuracy and velocity
just all-around talent thanks for the
opportunity to answer a question
listening from Australia I don't know
how much you've studied Trevor Lawrence
but based on what you've seen so far is
there any comparison in any of these
metrics between him and the best
quarterback in football no I can't say
that there is I mean Trevor Lawrence is
awesome and don't get me wrong here and
he's got every chance to be the number
one
the draft next year and deserves to be
in that conversation
mahomes Mike mahomes is one of those
guys when I turned on the film of his
last year at Texas Tech I started I just
kept going oh my gosh oh my gosh holy
cow what a throw
why isn't anybody talking about this guy
being the number one pick of the draft I
mean I I just can't tell you how blown
away it is I was by him and you know
anybody that doesn't want to believe me
or whatever go back and look at my old
videos on bleacher report I said it from
the get-go
you know Lawrence is really awesome he's
got a real good arm it's better than Jo
burrows it was the number one pick this
year but I think more Lawrence is more
of a you know it's it's he's got the
whole arsenal is available to him as far
as throwing I mean all the clubs in the
bag touch can drive the ball with power
as hard as he wants all of those things
but you know I don't think he's in that
mahomes class of tight players I think
he's more of like a more polished Justin
Herbert or we saw you know at the number
six pick this year a slightly more
talented version of like a Daniel Jones
who was the number six pick last year I
look at him kind of like that but very
poised played in a lot of big-time games
and you know can run throw got it all we
saw that the last two years in college
football and it's gonna be fascinating
to see what decisions he makes from a
business standpoint about the coming
days and the college season is in flux
at some point he's got to just pull the
plug and say I I'm not doing it I mean
all depends upon length of schedule
where the games are gonna be played the
circumstance is everything how much prep
there's gonna be before the games start
but at some point the business decision
will need to be made by Trevor Lawrence
as to whether or not this is something
that even makes sense for him playing
one more year or just waiting until he
enters the draft I think he'd still be
one of the top picks even if he doesn't
play alright my important question from
Tyler Forness what was your favorite
memory or scene from Jerry Stiller and
for me it's simple and last night I was
down in the barn watching old Seinfeld
episodes that included Jerry Stiller
playing Frank Costanza and there are
plenty of great scenes in great moments
and he steals every scene he's in
but to me the best one is when the
Costanza's are having dinner with
feroz's in advance of george and sita
and Susan's wedding and out of nowhere
because they're having Cornish game hen
so it's not there is at least a
connection to what's happening Frank
says let me get this straight
you've got the rooster the hen and the
chicken the rooster goes with the hen so
who's having sex with the chicken and
mr. Ross says the they're all chickens
the rooster has sex with all of them to
which frank says that's perverse that to
me is the ultimate grin I know he didn't
write the line and I haven't heard that
he had led the line I just think that
whole scene that whole moment to me I
don't know that I'd want to be
remembered for a scene like that once
I'm dead but hey he's a comedian he
wanted to entertain people to me that's
gonna be the enduring memory of Jerry
Stiller aka Frank Costanza that's
perverse yeah that's pretty good you
know listen I'm not the Seinfeld you
know you know what do I want to say you
know view where you are I don't have
quite the knowledge I don't sit there
and know every show to the extent you do
but when I always think of like Jerry
Stiller I mean I the first thing I think
I'm on the Seinfeld show it is you know
him yelling dalbol gavest like him just
doing that is always the mental image I
get of him saying that or when George
was moved and living at home and having
to deal with that those scenes were
really hilarious too but I think the
whole like del Boca Vista thing is
probably the one thing that really jumps
out to me about Jerry Stiller and let me
just add this and and I don't want to
get it's not necessarily political it's
more sociological than anything else but
I grew up in the 70s and the world was
very different in the 70s the
traditional roles of men and women in
the family unit very very different than
it is now and I remember as a young boy
watching The Carol Burnett Show and she
introduced a couple who are married and
they have different names and Mira and
Jerry Stiller and the idea of the wife
not having the same last name as the huz
in 1973 was incredibly foreign to most
people especially to little kids right
and then she's funny arguably funnier
than him and she's taller than him by
like three or four inches it's just like
turned upside down what as a kid in the
70s the environment that you're in
you're you're processing what the adults
perceive the roles to be of husband and
wife in a household and he he had the
self-confidence in himself as you would
say he had the security as to who he was
he would marry someone taller than him
funnier than him go ahead keep your name
I don't care and that just was like a
small little dot at a time when the
world really was very different that I
don't know it's just a stone in the
development of the world we now live in
where things like oh they love a woman
kept her name when she married her
husband all right that's but no big deal
it happens all the time now but but just
that to me and again I don't want to go
too deep with this but it was so
different from what you were used to
seeing in the 70s growing up and I think
it was a good thing and I think it was a
good message for men out there about you
know being secure and who you are even
if her wife's taller than you even if
she's funnier than you even if she
chooses to keep her name so I don't know
I probably bored you to death with that
but I I was thinking of that last night
that you know looking back on that at
the time it really was significant to me
way ahead of this time I mean yeah I
mean it's significant I mean you bored
me a little bit they're going down
member leigh.m is still so it is it just
shows you how smart he was how evolved
he was to know and like you're right
self-confident to realize that a lot of
that stuff is just bull crap and doesn't
mean anything anyways alright Cory jóska
it's any consideration to bring a new
pup into the house for you or Chris
Simms we talked about this briefly when
we were doing the big sell for the
Beverly Hills Dog Show 8 p.m. Eastern
NBC on Sunday night you know you've
already got to and you've got chickens
and you've got cats all I have is the
dog I really want the second dog here's
why I think I won't get the second dog
because the first dog has locked onto my
wife and every
where Jill goes the dog is there I mean
for whatever reason Jill's the Alpha and
the dog is with Jill all the time now if
Jill's not here dogs with me all the
time
I'm the beta I am that's fine I'm the
Jerry Stiller in this hair I have no
problem with that but but her concern is
cuz I want to get a dog that follows me
all over the place I want the I want my
dog you've got your dog I want my dog
she's concerned that she'll have two
dogs follow her all over the place which
probably will happen which probably is
why we're not gonna get a second dog
Kris well I think you know I do think
that you could pull it off I do you know
one you know what I think that that
other dog that puppy will either realize
oh wow this this is this is Jill's dog
over here Basie and it'll start to
gravitate towards you because it'll
realize that you know Macey doesn't love
you as much so I could see that
happening certainly or Jill ends up you
know liking the puppy and then Macey
realizes oh man I'm not the favorite
anymore and then she is relegated to
having to you to be the favorite you
know so that that could happen like we
have our dog Toto my little girl was
obsessed with Toto Toto was a Karen
Terrier we got Bentley and he was a cute
all-black German Shepherd and man Toto
got thrown out of the window in a hurry
German Shepherd now and Toto's moved on
to me and my wife now is the favorite so
it certainly can happen that way too
well I don't know that I'm gonna find
out and it sounds like you're not gonna
find out what happens when a third dog
gets its way into the mix no way two
dogs three cats three chickens and two
bunny I mean a bunny B beehives outside
of my window where I'm sitting right
here we got two different hives of bees
too so we got enough going on here I
don't want anything else on my damn
house or yard anymore I'm not messing
with beehives man they sting they don't
bother you unless you went in there and
tried to steal their honey you can walk
right by their hives they do they're not
aggressive by nature they're only
aggressive if you start
to mess with them then they're gonna get
involved with you but they really they
sit out here and they're in the Sun and
it's unbelievable to watch the team work
and what they do and everything like
that how they rally around the queen bee
and she's the boss it's it's very
interesting to see how they operate you
know it's funny all these different
lines from all the various Seinfeld
episodes it seemed to fit any occasion
we were talking about Frank Costanza
earlier you talked about bees and
getting stung by a bee there's a moment
in one of the seasons and I'm not to the
point where I can recite chapter and
first in one of the shows George has
fallen and injured his knee and Jerry
points out to Elaine that George was
running from a bee which last one before
we wrap this up just saying asks where
the Falcons ahead of the game when they
pump Freight
fake crowd noise into the Georgia Dome
obviously they got busted for that using
fake crowd noise to enhance the ambient
noise and that's a story now because
there are reports and Joe Buck from
Fox's flat out said it's a done deal
although Andrew Marsh on to the New York
Post says it's not a done deal that the
network's will use fake crowd noise and
possibly virtual fans so when they cut
to a wide shot there'll be an image of
fans in the stands even if fans aren't
there Chris I don't think they need any
of that stuff I think the game is good
enough to survive without basically a
laugh track I mean plenty of great
sitcoms have worked without being you
know informed as a viewer what's funny
and what's not funny we know what
compelling we know when to cheer we know
when to boo we know when to scream I
don't like it I don't like it but we'll
see what happens now you know I'll keep
an open mind I just don't think it's
necessary but maybe it is necessary for
the casual fan and if pro football is
the only sports that's happening this
fall maybe that we will be more casual
fans that need to be indoctrinated into
the game and need to be coached with
that ambient sound that extra sound not
the ambient sound but the artificial
sound on on when to get excited about
what's happening in front of them well I
mean I mean I'm with you right okay and
you know the Falcons yeah the crowd
noise always thought the Colts did that
in the old RCA Dome and even the Vikings
back in
and you know their day on the old dare
you how dare I
the Metrodome I mean it yeah the
Metrodome excuse me so there was always
those rumors of that what go ahead I got
I got two seats from that Stadium did I
ever tell you that yeah you know what I
think I do remember you telling me that
it was just really cool and I like that
that's yeah it's good to have that I
have two seats from the old Yankee
Stadium which is a important to me
because I'm such a big Yankee fan but
you know with the crowd noise things I'm
with you where I don't need to hear the
fake crowd noise but I will say this you
know if I'm the NFL and also I'm the
team that's playing at home you know I
don't know maybe this is what you do to
create a home-field advantage for the
excitement of the matter right to where
hey if you're the home team you know the
NFL sets forth the rule you can make
fake crowd noise up to this decibel
level when the other teams on offense to
you know make it harder on them to give
you some sense of a home-field advantage
I can see that being a very real
possibility instead of just being two
teams that are like oh yeah we're
playing in this city but who cares where
we're playing there's nobody here and it
doesn't really affect the game that way
other than we had a travel here you know
I think that would be something that
they might talk about and deliberate
about a little bit now look there's
there's one way to do this where the
sound would be supplied only for the TV
broadcast so they wouldn't hear it at
the stadium but if we do have a
situation where the games in Florida
have fans the games in California don't
and there's a competitive imbalance
right you would or should allow the
teams that are hosting games in stadiums
without fans to use crowd noise it would
all have to be negotiated and executed
properly and you'd have representatives
from both teams involved in making sure
that the sound levels were right I mean
it really becomes a can of worms but I
think it's fair I think it balances out
that inherent distinction between not
having fans for some teams and having
fans for others alright one last email
that I just received and this is an
important topic that we need to address
before we go this comes from Terence
Searcy have you noticed ghost
the orbs floating around Chris during
your broadcast are you worried about
potential demonic possession of your
co-host I don't know that anyone has
told you this but apparently there are
some ghostly orbs that are floating
around in the background of your shot
Chris well I mean I would think it's
just the human
I don't know the trees that are out here
in my yard or whatever else now there
could be ghosts here my house is 295
years old so the good B could be some
British soldiers just walking behind me
right now that we're here for the
Revolutionary War I'm gonna ask them if
they want some coffee or a cup of tea
maybe they do I don't know I'm not
scared of them either way I don't care
yeah I mean I look at it this way I
remember when I was a kid I was scared
of all that crap you make it this long
in life without seeing any tangible
evidence of ghosts or anything like that
of course I'm probably inviting you know
some sort of a poltergeist infiltration
in my house tonight but you get to a
point where you're like none of that
stuff is going on as I say that my phone
is sliding across the desk I gotta go
literally Chris enjoy your weekend great
week as always we'll do this again on
Monday I'll be back Friday with big cat
from his place in Brooklyn and we'll be
updating the website around the clock
Chris will be doing Chris Sims on button
later today I'll do a PFT p.m. at some
point either way you can find is pretty
much anywhere and we'll see you Friday
morning bright and early for another PFT
line via
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports